my dear brothers and sisters may Allah
bless you all a brother sent me a tweet
from Brother
uh his brother Mela guide him
and firstly let me let me make something
clear
please
don't come to me by saying he just
debated Robert Spencer our brothers
is better a thousand times is better
than
let me make that clear okay because oh
you are you siding with the non-muslims
we're not all right this brother he
keeps putting up tweets
on his Twitter keep tweeting things lion
slandering the Selfies all right is it a
Time speak out
we'll try to be nice with him before in
the first video I made all right try to
address him with respect and respectful
manner but alhamdulillah I said I hope
you're not going to be like Mohammed and
guess what exactly following the food
says and this is the way people of
desires and misguidance
and please don't come to me brother look
how eloquent how he speaks he's oh he's
so eloquent are you jealous the way he
debates
you both and all the brothers and
sisters in Islam may Allah bless us with
the way following the way of the self
the way debates
any person can do it
because you prepare it five months right
down where you're gonna say get us at
the the statistics and so on majority of
his debate is atheism against statistics
Christianity I guess statistics there's
no quranism it is
no one can do it yes if you know how to
have a dialogue and discussion on a spot
remember the ayats and the Hadith you
know
anyway
all these emotional tactics that people
of misguided are known to use it don't
use it because all you are clearing out
uh uh the lies against selfies they side
with the against the Muslims no my
brother Daniel is better than a thousand
times of of Pharaoh's name Robert
Spencer and and Hanami all right but
guess what he said subhanallahu
alhamdulillah we made video about him
he's coming out it's going we're going
to release it soon but it's quick
quanish Allah I said my argument against
is not simple that they have rejected
self-ism while pretending to be selfish
is that they have rejected Sunni Islam
as a whole so look at that
Asher a liar
don't you know Allah
if you speak speak with Justice
believe
the self
acted itself
refuted atheism
not based upon statistics and I'm not
saying you cannot utilize statistics
please don't misquote me today is a date
I'm not gonna I'm not going to leave no
room for the Liars to utilize any
opportunity to let and guess us let me
carry your Miracle of income Allah
even with our enemies and non-muslims
what about those who are Muslims except
if you believe quotes
their lives
religion to politics
I don't know maybe someone hacked your I
mean I'm doubting it maybe maybe someone
hacked your your Twitter page
indeed they have registered to Liberal
politics
activists
posing as teachers of religion
brother I I'm doubting maybe someone
hacked your your your your Twitter page
brother
are you are you mentally stable
are you mentally when I mean like if if
you said this actually this is calamity
and those who I would do they need to
come out and and say okay stop lying
subhanallah so day and night refruiting
Christianity day and nights ended to
share you have Allah
allahed until the lowest part of the
teacher of sharia you know they're like
branches is the best teaching in every
time in every place
everywhere and every place and any time
you claim that we we are the liberal
activist
s
why you lying brother
's defend the spread of shirk and the
abolition of sharia and Muslim lands as
part of the liberal political program
I mean
I don't know I think those are with Him
cooperating with him promoting his
videos you need to come out and and
speak out
we speak out maybe I'm thinking maybe
I'm doubting
maybe someone hacked his his Twitter
page but there is other tweets same it
was from his Twitter page
or worse
how can you say that guide you
I mean I I use something's happening to
your mind debating too much Christians
and atheists and too much debates in
debates and debating you're losing your
mind
subhanallah how can you claim
foreign
country
and
you're gonna say I only ask you if I go
to this country they're gonna come out
it's going to make it harder
bro stop lying
stop lying I said you are alive and get
selfies
guide you
and we're not gonna say whatever you did
you haven't done nothing for Islam
look how just this debate uh you you you
you you did the reputation which you
exposed some of the Liberals and we
asked her to reward you for that but how
can you how can you lie
is
unknown do we have the salaf that there
is no salvation there is no Safety and
Security there's no success except by by
going back on the Sunnah for the Muslim
leaders and the Muslim there's no
success success for them and there's no
salvation except
going back to the Quran to have the
salaf and you claim that
foreign
and I hope you come out and and take it
back and make it so much Allah we ask
Allah to guide you